thousand years ago we used to have whole
dictionaries of sex in Arabic and one of
them one of these medieval dictionaries
imaginatively entitled and forgive me on
the video the language of [ __ ] first
I wanted to ask because we tend to think
of the the Arab world in very political
terms why sex why is that so important
yeah and as the as the focus of your
book yeah I appreciate you know spending
five years travelling across the Arab
world talking to people about sex can
either strike you as a dream job or a
highly dubious occupation but the reason
for it is twofold I mean it's why sex
and why why the Arab world so right I
became interested in the Arab world
because of my connection to the Arab
world I'm half Egyptian my family lived
in Egypt most of them I carry an
Egyptian passport and I'm Muslim but as
was mentioned I grew up in Canada and I
never really thought much about my Arab
heritage until September 11th and the
events of that day in the aftermath
really prompted me to think what is
going on in this part of the world I
heard so many people talk about those
Muslims and those Arabs but I said look
you know what I have a possibility to
discover this on my own I have a
privileged access and so I wanted to
reorient my career to the Arab region
the reason I chose sex was because of my
connection to hiv/aids and if you want
to understand HIV in the Arab world you
have to look at sex because it is the
major route of transmission for most
cases in the region most people think we
don't have a lot of HIV in the Arab
world and that's actually true for the
moment we have these isolated
concentrated epidemics but I can tell
you there are only two parts of the
world in which the number of new
infections from HIV and the number of
deaths from HIV are increasing and one
of those two regions is the Arab region
and so I wanted to stand what is going
on around sex
the taboos around sex and how is that
affecting our response to HIV but then I
realized that beyond the actual sort of
sexual act and risky practices in that
very sort of narrow biological medical
definition of sex but if one looked at
sexuality more broadly so these are the
attitudes and behaviors of beliefs and
values they actually give you a lens
onto society because it's interacts with
politics and with economics and with
religion and with tradition and gender
and and generations and at the end of
the day if you really want to know what
people start by looking inside their
bedrooms and that's exactly what I do
and this one of the one of the things
that attracted me to your book it may
seem a little odd bringing in another
country but Ireland is a country that
has been in the news a lot lately at
least in my Twitter feed because I've
been following the fallout from the
Magdalene laundries
does everybody here know about that
these were this was a gulag of Prisons
for-profit laundries run by the Catholic
Church and the focus has been on the
involvement of the church and the state
starting in 1922 and Ireland became
independent and what has really struck
me for the past couple of months is just
how the church came to power after
independence and really abused people on
a widespread basis and you know got got
government power as well and of course I
feel like we're seeing echoes of this in
Egypt with the Muslim Brotherhood that
theocrats can use the sort of rhetoric
of independence and rebellion to take
power and I was just wondering if you
have some thoughts about that and how
that's affecting people it's interesting
the the conservative attitudes towards
sexuality you find beyond the Islamic
conservatives
and if I can just give you one example
so I was down in Tahrir Square you know
at the center of the uprisings this is
in 2011 and I was talking to young
protesters about their fight for
political freedom and I asked them do
you think this political freedom could
ever lead to sexual freedom and one of
the young women I spoke to quite a
highly-educated student-t literature
student but from a rural area
she said yes absolutely you know there
are some people here they have a free
sexual life I believe in this Paris 68
it is forbidden to forbid I wish we
could have that here so she took me
across the square to where people were
camped out and these are the real
diehard protesters and they were you
know fighting and and literally dying in
the streets around us stuff fighting the
security forces and I met one of her
fellow students and I asked him liberal
God asked him do you think that this
political freedom will lead to sexual
freedom and he said to me no no no no no
this is not the freedom we are fighting
for the political freedom is one thing
we are Arabs we are Muslims we believe
in the marriage institution and that's
the citadel of which I speak in my book
that the only socially accepted context
for sexual life is family approved
religiously approved state registered
matrimony he said that's all we want we
don't want anything else and this is a
guy who is you know on the cutting edge
of the liberal movement and so you don't
have to be an Islamic conservative to
have to adhere to these conservative
values and and that's why I think the
rise to political prominence of the
Islamists in Egypt is actually in a
funny way not a bad not a bad thing for
those of us who are interested in sexual
rights because these conservative
currents during the long years of
dictatorship this rise of Islamic
fundamentalism was happening under the
table you couldn't challenge it we
didn't really talk about it now it is on
the table and we are discussing it very
openly and we are starting to talk about
who speaks for Islam what is the role
of Islam in public life and that's
absolutely key because one of the points
I make in the book is that today we have
these very narrow interpretations on
Islam on a whole variety of issues not
just sex but there have been times in
history when we have had much more open
thinking about about all matters
including the role of women including
sexual issues and we have gravitated to
this very narrow place and this is
largely to do with the rise of Islamic
conservatism but now it is on the table
we are talking about it and people are
challenging it now and this is a very
important step forward I think for
achieving sexual rights in in the years
to come we all speak for Islam each of
us as Muslims should be speaking for
Islam this is the beauty in my opinion
as a practicing Muslim this is the
beauty of his love it
ekta hat which is the is independent
reasoning in Islam is an individual duty
they may tell us otherwise the the
people who want to use religion to
control us will tell us differently but
now we have a moment to stand up and say
no it is our right to think for
ourselves and to speak for ourselves and
if we do that in politics we can do that
in religion and hopefully we will see
one day start to do that in sexual life
as well sorry sorry I can't yes
absolutely not and that's the nature of
a democracy now foods that's the nature
of the democracy 10 years when I started
this book in 2007 we didn't have that
space to disagree and now we do that's
that's the step forward for us and I
think every I think every religion has
this problem that every religious
culture has this problem of people
disagreeing or and some people deciding
that they will impose their
interpretation on everybody but one
another aspect of this I'm curious about
is you actually mentioned this in some
of your interviews and I think in the
book what's the role of economic freedom
here I mean what I wanted what I'm
trying to say is there's a difference I
think there is a difference between
affluence and economic independence
because you can be very rich or come
from a rich family and be extremely
beholden to them and so have no sexual
freedom in fact sometimes very wealthy
people are compelled to procreate
they can't choose to have a life without
children and I was just wondering also
the the stories we sometimes hear in the
news about the Arab world focus on very
rich people very powerful people and
their sexual crimes or peccadilloes but
my sense of this is that you're more
interested in the sexuality of the the
middle classes or the emerging is that
correct the the people who want to be
middle class the book largely focuses on
middle class voices but there are
certainly people from all social all
elements in the social spectrum okay one
of the reasons there's mainly middle
class voices is that I wanted in the
book not just focus on problems we know
there are lots of sexual problems in the
Arab world they're in the news all the
time one of the things I tried to do in
relation to the problems is to assemble
the evidence what do we know empirically
in real serious research terms
about sexual life in the Arab world but
what I tend to focus on in the book are
solutions people who are trying to find
their way out of this these constraints
and those innovators tend to come from
the educated classes the middle classes
but certainly when I was for example
meeting with sex workers across the
region I mean these are often
desperately poor women this is not a
lifestyle choice for them they have no
other economic choice and this gets
cheap to your point
who in economics is a real driver of
sexual behavior anywhere in the world
and it can have take very explicit forms
so for example there is a type of
prostitution in Egypt it's known as
summer' marriage in which wealthy
visitors from the Gulf states will come
they do a lot of shopping in Egypt great
for the economy one of the things these
male tourists often buy as a girl and
there are particular villages near Cairo
in which girls are supplied for summer
marriage and in Islam sex outside of
marriage is Vinh not it's it's adultery
and it is haram it's forbidden
so they give this form of sex work and
Islamic cover they write a contract
which sort of checks all the boxes in
terms of marriage dubious intent aside
and they enter into these affairs the
girls spend maybe two weeks a couple of
weeks with the men the men go home and
the girls go back to their families
and it is a source of tremendous angst
for many of for many of these for many
of these women and that's driven by
economics and their parents the parents
are essentially prostituting their girls
for the for the money so you talked
about I was actually very interested in
this because you talked about how it the
sort of the structure of it and that the
money is paid to the family and also one
impression I got from this was that the
girls or the women who do summer
marriages temporary marriages are they
don't call themselves prostitutes they
they have they're operating in a kind of
gray area
no one calls even Frank sex workers
would never self-identify as sex workers
but in my experience in the Arab region
right but it's but if you work in a
brothel still don't self-identify right
okay what word would you use you mean
the other issue of terminology so just
as an aside so in Arabic we have now
sort of come down to quite a restricted
vocabulary around sex which is one of
the problems because most of the
language people use is from the street
and this is really inhibiting for women
because the language is considered to be
vulgar and women have a lot of trouble
talking about sexuality because the
burden of the stigma and the taboo falls
on them and so added to that they don't
even have a language to speak about sex
in a respectful manner so it just I'll
just finish this point what's
interesting that is that a thousand
years ago we used to have whole
dictionaries of sex in Arabic and one of
them one of these medieval dictionaries
imaginatively
entitled and forgive me on the video the
language of [ __ ] included over a
thousand verbs for to have sex and now
we're so restricted people don't even
want to talk about it and many people in
the Arab region actually speak feel more
comfortable speaking about sex in
English more in French or in Hebrew if
they're Palestinians and in Israel than
they do in in Arabic and so often these
women just will not they'll call
themselves workers for example yeah but
they won't actively identify as sex
workers well actually we have that here
a lot of sex workers I mean sex worker
is a kind of political term very few
people use it outside of activism so
there are a lot of girls here who will
say I'm an escort or I'm a working girl
and they won't use very clinical
language for similar reasons just
cultural if I can give you so in in
Egypt for example the word for for
prostitute is Shan muta and it's like it
essentially [ __ ]
okay and
is the only word that people you know on
the street well we recognize with my un
hat on I often use UN speak so in
particular for men who have sex with men
there's a very long term for this in
Arabic but if you want to talk about
homosexual you caught you call them
Mythili and when I was speaking to some
very educated doctors and talking about
Mythili I'm Italian and they said what
are you talking about and then they said
ah you mean show ass and show what as an
Arabic means deviant and this is the
term which is originally used even in
the media so we have a real problem
around around language sorry gentlemen
you who didn't get a question Muslim
culture when someone is a sex worker is
that how they're perceived are you also
asking whether this is seen as a job or
an identity like whether a job versus an
identity I mean I'm thinking that's kind
of where you're going is that what he's
asking I think in the context of sex
work it's such a shameful activity for
yeah I mean there's a lot of self stigma
it's one of the great obstacles that is
faced in even trying to even vaguely
organize and I'm gonna use the
politically correct term now it's sex
worker baby hmm I'm gonna use you and
speak here it's very hard to organize
them in one of the irony's around sex
work is that it is both the most visible
face of sex and the in the outer world
how many people here have been to Dubai
okay how many people have noticed the
sex workers in the lobby of your hotel
we're not so far from the Arab world
after so so it's it's a very visible
face but it's also an invisible face
because most of the women do not want to
come forward when we when we do work on
HIV it's incredibly hard to engage sex
workers female sex workers male sex
workers and then you have sex with men
who are actually seen as even be more
stigmatized because of the homophobia
actually are much more outgoing and
largely because they are men and
therefore no matter what their sexuality
is it's easier than being a woman
because also is it not the case that
sometimes man engage in temporary
marriage you talked about that as as if
they were I mean escorts or yes yes
gigolos or whatever I mean for money
basically absolutely and it's it's it's
a double standard really yeah there are
these also female sex tourists who come
to the some of the resorts and they
often have relationships with with the
men and it's not as frowned upon as if a
woman like these summer at these summer
marriages there's a real double standard
but get their Western there their
Western women I'm one of the brokers who
was involved in the summer marriage
business finding girls for the Arab men
gulf men visiting he said hmm yes we do
occasionally get women from the Gulf
coming but they actually want to get a
passport so it's so it has to be an
official marriage he said wow it's a lot
of work I'm not sure it's worth the
money but to pickup your point on
identity it's quite it's quite
interesting because you see that duality
in amongst men who have sex with men
it's a whole spectrum of sexuality there
because some men in the region most
certainly do self identify as gay and
yet a lot of men who have sex with with
other men
we completely reject those labels they
just don't feel that they apply to them
so their sexual identities is a very
it's much more fluid in the Arab region
and as one very cogent really articulate
queer activist in Lebanon told me you
know really you know what are you
talking about Shireen about sexual
identities in the Arab region we don't
even have individual identities she said
I am on the record of the government as
the daughter of my father and if I were
to marry I would become the wife of my
husband I don't exist as an individual
how do you expect me to have a sexual
identity and it really comes to the core
of the difficulty of achieving you know
the ascent the essence of a section of
sexual rights which is a a happy
satisfying pleasurable sexual life free
of coercion and discrimination and
violence if you don't have those
individual rights and individual
freedoms recognized and respected by the
state it's very difficult to achieve
them in the context of a patriarchal
family so we have a miles to go before
any of this is conceivable in most of
the Arab world and you know one of the
things I wanted to ask about was so that
the temporary marriage the girl whose
parents particularly her father but that
the families involved in the deal the
family benefits from the deal of the
money in one case you described a
situation where the father received the
money he gave some to the daughter she
was doing all of the the sexual labor
but you know she's part of this unit so
some of this money is being used for
another
education and and then I was thinking is
temporary marriage harmful and so forth
because of the sex work or is it more
about how the money is distributed in
other words are there people in the
brothels for example who just keep all
of the money and perhaps dole out a
little bit to their family where it's a
little bit reversed which is what we do
in the West a lot of sex workers come
here to the States for example from
other countries to work and they'll send
money back home but the family doesn't
know how much money they're making they
become dependent on on the sex worker
member and she or he you know has a
little power to and I'm just wondering
does that scenario exist yet or in you
know in Egypt in other parts of the Arab
world so let me tell you a story which
is not from sex work but actually
illustrates that dynamic very clearly so
one of the young women I met in Egypt
her name is Imani and she comes from the
conservative south of the country Amman
he is a tour guide and she makes quite a
lot of money and as a consequence of
that she's actually the main breadwinner
for her family her entire family or her
father and her brothers and sisters are
dependent upon her one day a young man
whom she had met through a friend came
to the parents brought his parents
wanted to marry a Manny and her parents
said no now she's in her late 20s and
although she has all the financial power
in the family again sometimes the
earning capacity she has none of the
control over her own life years past
they kept arguing with the parents she
wanted to marry him they said no and one
of the reasons they said no is that they
didn't want to lose her income I know to
the new couple so she and her and
interpreted her clandestine fancy
decided to take matters into their own
hands so they traveled to Cairo and they
had what's known as an orphan marriage
this is a customary marriage depending
on whom you ask
it is Islamically permissible or not the
criteria are actually quite flexible in
Islam as to what constitutes and
but there are some scholars who will say
that these marriages are permissible and
that's why she had it because to her as
a practicing Muslim it was inconceivable
that she would have sex outside of
marriage she needed a marriage framework
and yet when I asked her but I many of
you are the breadwinner you have the
financial power why do you not just get
married in defiance of your parents and
she said I cannot do that it is not my
reputation
it is my family's reputation it is my
father's reputation he is the great man
at the mosque if I were to go against
him they would say he had an impolite a
disobedient daughter I cannot go against
my family and and so that's a very clear
illustration that having the money
doesn't give you the power especially if
you're a woman but right but are there
in the brothels for example are you more
likely to meet somebody who is more in
control of her finances not in my
experience no no okay I was just
wondering because he works no matter
where you are I mean most most sex
workers are either under the control of
a perk you up pimp or they're under the
control of the the madam who is running
running the show they have very little
very little at all very little autonomy
baby no you never you're talking about
Egypt or because it's a big region and
looking at Morocco and Tunisia yeah I
mean I should point out that there are
is actually legal sex work is illegal in
most of the Arab world except there are
these pockets which are legacies of the
colonial period in which sex work is
legal a certain form of it and that's
most pronounced in Tunisia where they do
have still a network of legal brothels
it's it's organized by the state they
have these regular medical exams they
earn a certain fixed fixed rate but
those those brothels are now under
attack by Islamists and it's not clear
how long that's
how have they succeeded in actually
shutting down a district a brothel
district into in Tunisia I mean I read
about this when it started happening I
was horrified yeah almost there used to
be they would close to 300 legal sex
workers in Tunisia before the uprising
it's probably down to less than 100 now
they used to have little brothel zones
in each of the major towns in Tunisia
now it's reduced to to Tunis and place
called sphax so the two major centers
and yes that's due to pressure from
islamís mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah my question is about the
self identification is an important step
in generating political consciousness so
I was wondering if you could comment
about how gay and lesbians in gay men
and lesbians and and queer people
generally in Egypt self-identify and
what state of political activism they're
in and how it's been affected by the
rise of the Muslim Brotherhood okay tall
order here alright in terms of
terminology I'm gonna talk about men who
have sex with men and women have sex
with women engage in same-sex relations
because as I said some people very
clearly self-identify as gay lesbian or
queer but that's in Mike's in or in
Arabic I mean but but but that's a
minority in my experience many people do
not and the political consciousness
you're talking about I mean there it
there there are little groups across the
Arab world and this is one of the sort
of sets of solutions I'm talking about
not just problems we have you know
crushing homophobia in in most of the
Arab region and if you were to come out
to your parents in in in Egypt the most
likely step would be an immediate trip
to the doctor to see if they can somehow
fix you and so reparative therapy is is
big across the the Arab region you know
religious conversion muslim christian
christian muslim highly controversial
matter of life and death
sexual conversion absolutely no problem
that is it how is it done I mean what's
the technique so it depends there is
sometimes there will be religious
healing that somehow the power of of
prayer and Quranic recitation will
sometimes which somehow switch you over
very often go to a general practitioner
and you'll get prescribed various
antidepressants or anxiolytics and get
you know fire and brimstone lecture um
there are some psychiatrists who
practice some more sort of how do I put
this a more funny more rigorous form of
repair
therapy does have some basis however
flawed but there is some method to it
but it's very it's it's it's it's the
routine if you come out to your parents
that's what's gonna happen to you in
terms of this sort of organizing there
are these extraordinary groups of young
activists they tend to be under age 40
they tend to be more educated they speak
very good English they are connected to
the wider world of LGBTQ activism there
is even something actually have a camp
now it's called multi kitnik camp where
the activists who work on these issues
from across the region come together
once a year in a secret location to
share experiences and to talk about how
do we move forward what's really
interesting about all these groups and
there are a minority of a minority all
right but when you talk to them they
know chapter and verse the history of
the gay rights movement in the West and
they can tell you with extreme precision
why they think it will not work in the
Arab world they want something
completely different they do not accept
you know identity politics sexual
identity politics they say what is the
point of us fighting for the rights of a
tiny minority irrespective of the
crushing homophobia if we do not achieve
justice and freedom and equality and
dignity for for everyone not just
minorities for everyone in you know
coming out of these oppressive systems
so it's a very different
conceptualization of how you would go
about getting getting achieving rights
and achieving space in my experience
most people who have sex with their own
sex or are transgendered or transsexual
are not looking for the freedom to come
out they want the freedom to stay in and
live their lives behind closed doors and
do as they choose they are looking for
privacy and one of the interesting
experiences I've had is working with
religious leaders and Manuel have sex
with men and you can only do this if you
talking about HIV so I was part of a
project that over the course of many
years brought these to you know chalk
and cheese groups together and we did
this under the aegis of HIV if we wanted
to talk about gay rights absolutely no
way would we get religious
to come to the table but this was a rich
mix if she sunny in man's and also
Christian clergy from across the
denominations and what was fascinating
is that over these years these groups
came together at the beginning there was
huge suspicion and particularly the
religious leaders had all these
extraordinary ideas about these men that
they were rapists and pedophiles and
that they were you know indulgent and
debauched and they had no idea of the
reality of these men's lives it seems
like the United States meetings and they
were talking about sort of conservative
values and well where is George Bush I
know it may not sound like Canada but it
sounds like the u.s. to me anyway yeah
you know these these issues are not
unique to the Arab world or the Islamic
world we see them across the the global
south and indeed in America as well but
what was most interesting about this
process of accommodation is that one of
the religious leaders I talked about in
the book he said look you know what
these these these men are our brothers I
want to find a way to reach out to them
I cannot tell them that their behavior
is halau but it is permitted although as
an aside as a side point there are some
Islamic scholars now elsewhere in the
Muslim world who are actually
questioning what is the taboo around
homosexuality you don't need what are
the what are they the canonical texts
really telling us about homosexuality in
Islam but that sort of thinking isn't
catching on in the Arab world as yet but
the point of commonality was privacy in
Islam we have a real emphasis on your
business is your business and it is a
sin to spy on someone else and if you
want to communion you want to accuse
someone of a crime you need to have four
eyewitnesses who are a nun coerced
confession so in this discussion about
privacy for example you can think that
there might be a way of accommodating
men you have sex with men within the
context of of Islam and that's exactly
what in my experience many of the men on
- that's what they're looking for but
this goes back to the point that there
are alternative interpretations within
Islam it's not a monolith and when the
conservatives give their point of view
they present it like there is no
alternative but that's simply not the
case
[Music]
and others and what about the non Arab
world are thinking particularly of
Turkey where women are demonstrating to
be able to put on a job and Iran where
they wish to Indonesia where we're not
sure yeah I mean I'll take the second
question first
I absolutely there are similar debates
going on in many parts of the Islamic
world I didn't actually look at them in
the context of my book and I can't speak
with any great Authority I I've read the
books that have better commenting on
this but you're right I mean there are
in many respects and other Muslim
countries they are further ahead in
tackling some of the issues that we are
grappling with in the Arab world and
quite frankly most of the innovation
around Islam is not coming from the
heart of Islam it's coming from outside
that's not really a surprise the
challenge we have now is in translating
that into the region and you already see
that with a number of NGOs that are
trying to for example deal with
sexuality in terms of trying to get it
into schools the the levels of sexual
knowledge and information in the Arab
world are really horrifying I mean the
story I always give about this is that I
was asked by young acquaintances who is
a student at Business School and one of
Egypt's leading universities and she
came to me and she asked me dr. Sydney
and I have a question I want to know if
I can become pregnant if my fiance
stands in front of the air conditioner
and it turns out that the only class
that she had had on a reproduction was
plant biology and she had confounded
pollen with sperm and so this is one of
the more educated people you can imagine
what's happening for the rest so there
are very interesting
models elsewhere on these sort of
sensitive issues and thanks to the
Internet in large part is now sort of
percolating into the region in terms of
the power of women absolutely and we and
we tend to underestimate that even in
the patriarchy women do have tremendous
influence and you see it in how they
raise their boys ma the key to getting
changed dealing with all the the taboo
particularly around women's sexuality
and women's independence is how do you
educate boys and girls not just in the
classroom but in the living room and
it's the key it's the key to changing
things so for example I talk about a
woman in my book
she runs a club Facebook site and radio
for divorced women because divorce is
still a huge taboo it's the rates are
increasing dramatically most of the Arab
world but a divorced woman is seen as a
as a as a broken woman as a loose woman
she often has to move home when she's
divorced and that's not just for
financial reasons it's not acceptable
for her to live as an independent woman
and I asked her this woman what do you
think about the ability of Western
people to have relations before marriage
that freedom and she paused them she
said you know I don't think that that's
such a great thing and I said what do
you not think it leads to stronger
marriages because you have a chance to
get to know each other she said no I
don't think so
just look at Madonna and her many
divorces but what she did Liz Taylor
well exactly and what she did say to me
though is that what I really admire in
the West is how boys are brought up and
how men and women interact within
marriage now of course people in the
Arab world know the West through the
internet and movies and television
series not a 20/20 vision on 20/20
vision on the Western sexual life
nonetheless what they are longing for is
to have that equality and companionship
and romance and really parody within
marriage in my experience many women do
and that's what they that's what they
are longing for what do they read in
there
well I have a whole section on that so
so the Harlequin novels so many many
women complain to me about how useless
their husbands were in bed and as one of
them said to me you know five minutes it
is over no kissing no cuddling nothing
he turns out he rolls over Falls to
sleep then he puts on the television and
so I thought this is so contrary to the
archetype of the of the Arab lover the
the chef you know the rude groans you so
I gave some of these books to my friends
in Egypt to read and they were
absolutely I mean they were just
flabbergasted wait which books which
books sorry
Oh in English anyway these books are not
really available yeah you know there
used to be in the 1960s and 70s these
books and so I went into a bookstore
with a friend that she said maja gaba
she's covered and we tried to find these
books and and they took her aside and
said you know madam you really should
not be asking
[Music]
yeah it was I was I actually was [ __ ]
oke if you know Cairo it's and it's in
downtown yes and they were just
flabbergasted at these at these at these
views but again it goes back to the
history because if you go back to the
long history of Arabic erotica thang are
going on and on and on about how to
please women sexually this is no
important and it stems from the history
of Islam that Islam is not anti sex
although it's perceived as such
absolutely and that's due to the
narrowing of interpretations but in its
essence Islam recognizes the power of
sex it tries to channel it but the
Prophet himself spoke movingly about the
importance of sexual pleasure for men
and for women
as a consequence of that we have
centuries of these books which go into
great detail about technique and all
that is lost today and and so the
question is as we move forward into what
we are hoping a new era how are we gonna
reopen that and rediscover that spirit
so these books are I mean the they have
a bit of a cult following in the West
what were books about sexual technique
or what what's happened to these books
are they so most of you were they
translated most of these books I read
them in in either English or French
they're more readily available in
translation right it's hard to get them
you've heard of a thousand and one
nights okay how many of you read 1001
nights or tales from them okay so
they're quite they're quite bawdy
actually and yet you know a couple of
years ago I think was 2009 there was a
move to try and have it banned in Egypt
mm-hmm conserve and this is long before
the Islamists that have ascended to
power so these books are largely lost
and it's in part due to the fact that
educational systems have wound down and
also there isn't people literacy rates
are very high but people don't actually
read very much anymore and that's
because of television
we're in large in in large part yes I
had well before we return to the room I
just had it
kind of bouncing off of this gentleman's
question about other Muslim countries
because Bangladesh is one country where
some of the most interesting sex worker
activism is happening and in fact you
probably know this the spokesperson for
the network of sex work projects which
is an international NGO is a Malaysian
lady transgender Muslim lady by the name
of Kartini Lama but is there a so
there's there's no assumption we don't
have to assume that this couldn't happen
in a in an Islamic environment but is
there a country in the Arab region that
you think is sort of poised has the
conditions to be the country where the
kind of the sex workers spring would
take place you know where sex workers
will come into their own politically in
that country and you know be a kind of
play a leading role for other sex
workers but you think it will never
happen or I mean what about Morocco or
Tunisia in Morocco and Tunisia sex
outside of marriage is actually illegal
in law we don't even have those laws in
Egypt right so you know is ironic Egypt
is now seen as highly conservative and
yet we don't have laws which explicitly
criminalize premarital sex or explicitly
criminalize sodomy but those laws are
present in Morocco and and Tunisia
now what this goes to show you is that
just having a law doesn't necessarily
change attitudes attitudes can be very
conservative new perspective of the
presence of a law if I can just go back
to share intimates question about power
within the family because this relates
to law so female genital mutilation
occurs why it's widespread in Egypt
about 90 percent of women under age 50
or circumsized 99 zero and if you look
at 15 to 17 year-olds because it's done
around age 9 to 12 they're about 80
percent circumcised
because it because it's acceptable it's
socially it's one of those aspects of
private life you can actually ask women
are you circumcised and they will tell
you now they may be more likely to say
yes than no because of the social
acceptability of FGM nonetheless I mean
it is we do have some data and it is
widespread the reason I'm bringing this
up is that it's women who make that
decision you talk about the power of
women men are not involved in that
decision-making process at all it's
mothers and grandmothers who who decide
and to go to the point about the law we
have a good law in Egypt that was passed
they moved by the mark regime to
criminalize FGM and many of the women I
have met don't pay any heed to it
whatsoever and in fact they are they
conceptualize FGM in some cases as a
form of resistance to an autocratic on
representative government whom they
think is in Hawk to the west or wasn't
Hawk to the west and is passing laws
which meddle in their private behavior
and this is none of the government's
business I'm guessing this is sounding
familiar to people in America we've had
a lot of hurt a lot of news reports from
Tucker Square then in terms of these
souls against women have become
apparently common all types of levels
amongst these are souls are police taken
upon themselves to do virginity tests
now to someone who is you know much more
Westerner this is all very almost
surrealistic so III think it's true and
has Egypt passed laws that women have by
walk must be virgins until marriage and
so any police officer can just dude some
bizarre check on the woman what's going
on here all related question there's a
film there was a full day but using
feminists about eight or ten years ago
said now and if you could talk about
that how realistic was life spent some
time in Tunisia I fluent in French nuts
in Arabic I thought it was factually
plausible but I don't have enough
knowledge to make that judgment okay so
about the virginity test as I say in the
book virginity remains what could best
be described as a big [ __ ] deal in
the Arab world it's very important it's
a complete double standard in Islam we
are enjoined to remain chaste before
marriage
and the Prophet asked us suggested that
we should fast that that would help us
he did not mean that we were supposed to
fast until our late 30s which is now the
average age of marriage but that's
another story the reality is that men
men will have relations before marriage
and but if women do the burden falls on
them very heavily and one consequence of
this for example is when I was in
Morocco looking at HIV outreach with sex
workers I met some young students who
were supplementing their income by
turning tricks on the Atlantic corniche
and when we offered them condoms they
said ah we don't need condoms there's no
chance of us getting pregnant we only do
anal sex mm-hmm and the reason for that
is that they wanted to preserve their
Hartman's and they wanted to get married
and they knew if they broke that that
they would be unable to marry and so
there is very much a double standard
around virginity and it's not just the
authorities who do virginity tests in
this case that you're talking about in
the Army mandated that that was more of
a tool of intimidation quite frankly
because they don't want women protesting
and one way to clear them out of the
streets is if you think you're going to
be physically violated by by the
authorities so that's more of a tool of
control there isn't one
there isn't one actually forced medical
testing which of which this is an
element was illegal under the Egyptian
Constitution but hey who cares what's in
the Constitution we had a great
Constitution during the Mubarak period
horrendous abuses of human of human
rights what's interesting though about
virginity testing it's not just the
authorities in Egypt there is a practice
called buffler & Dhokla used to consist
of and still does in some villages in
which on the wedding night the
traditional Midwife would come into the
bar into the
marriage chamber and she would pierce
the woman's hymen and they would collect
the blood and so it's clear that you
have delivered an intact bride this is
really important not for the woman's
herself but for the family because the
woman's honor is related to the family's
honor and the men's honor and that's
about delivering a virgin bride
so Dhokla now has become what's called
da club a Frankie so what happens is
that you put a sheet down on the wedding
on the wedding bed and the bride is
expected to bleed onto it and then you
take the cloth and you give it to the
family and it's not just some sort of
rural practice or uneducated persons
practice middle-class people do this as
well it's very important it's very
important I'm on some time who's I know
of the film I have not seen it but what
I can tell you is that this image of
Tunisia as being this incredibly curved
progressive place under Ben Ali for
women's rights and it's the only country
in the Arab world that offers abortion
on demand but it wasn't they had laws
against homosexuality had laws against
premarital sex at a whole range of legal
structures but more importantly at some
of the most horrendous human rights
abuses that are not only against sexual
rights they're against women's rights
but they're against men's rights as well
so very often laws around women's rights
are used have been used as a sort of
cover basically you can appear to be
progressive to outsiders and the reality
is that your practices are as aggressive
as anywhere else that's ostensibly
conservative in the Arab world sorry
sorry about this can we just take this
poor form and we'll come back there's
one female a general mutilation to make
their daughters were attractive for
wife's to the man is that
or something else going on it's question
one I don't wanna answer though I'm very
very good through their number of
reasons why they do it and one is
tradition they all will dress it up in
religion and say it's you know mandated
but it isn't I mean they're member of
religious figures you say it's
completely contrary to both Christianity
and Islam the main driver for it is that
they believe that the clitoris is a
dynamo of female sexual energy and if
you do not curb it girls will wander
before marriage and they will make
excessive demands of their husbands
during marriage and these will be
marriage killers and remember marriage
is the Citadel it's the it's the center
of all sexual life and in my experience
most people do not want to pull down the
Citadel most people want to get inside
the Citadel and so the challenge for us
in the years to come is to actually how
do we build out the Citadel how do we
begin to take in other populations like
unwed mothers for example or divorced
women or the biggest single problem that
Tracy going back to your earlier
question of economics mhm if not the
cost of marriage has increased so much
in the Arab world and we have so little
employment for young people that they
can't afford to get married
so we have these legions of young people
now we're having to wait till their 30s
but they're not supposed to be having
sex what on earth are they going to do
of course they do have relations it goes
under the table so the question is how
can we build out the Citadel take in
these populations take in some of the
tricky issues like abortion the
difficult terrain like sexuality
education and then eventually we pull
down the Citadel from the inside and
that's in my opinion how social change
will occur in the art world the other
question is I read a news article in The
New York Times about how in Afghanistan
the politically elite men often will
have a boy 10 11 12 is from a poor
family who not only serves some tea but
is forced to have sex with them how
common did you find that sort of
practice the article was talking about
how American soldiers are finding
themselves
powerless to stop this practice I didn't
look at Afghanistan because I looked at
the Arab world in Afghanistan is outside
the Arab world I have to say that in the
long history of homosexuality in the
Arab region this was quite common you
remember the cultural construct which
largely a-plus today is that if you're
the active partner you're not really
homosexual you're just a man and so the
stigma is on the passive the passive
partner historically who tended to be a
boy and in fact if you go back to these
great books of Arabic erotica they have
whole sections on something called
creeping which is the art of essentially
a creeping up on the boy and raping him
but again it's about power right it's
about the power of the adult male and
the passive younger younger male so
there is most definitely a tradition of
this although it is Haram everyone knew
it was hot on it happened and but today
the problem is that there's a real
denial right that these that
homosexuality exists in the Arab world
and if there is an acknowledgment it's a
Western import and the other problem was
is that the young boys tried to run away
they'd either be tortured or even killed
it's it's I'm not familiar with the the
situation in Afghanistan quick question
and I generally despise questions in the
form of a statement but I don't know if
you mentioned American soldiers abroad
and I wondered if my experience is at
all representative to your findings or
if this is an outlier but in rural in
Iraq it was not uncommon for male Iraqi
soldiers to have sex with one another
this was justified two ways as far as I
was aware what was oh it's just amazing
which I take to mean rape or well this
is brutal Iraq there are the male the
female to male ratio is so low and
marriage is so important in order to
have sex that's this is essential
essentially masturbation and then a very
odd troubling and I'm sorry to be a huge
downer experience was that a father came
to the base with his child
I think child was seven we had the best
Hospital in the region obviously and
thought there's some sort of urinary
issue
I said I met the father I saw the father
the father was absolutely concerned
devastated wondered what was wrong with
his son found out later that the father
was told by the the doctors that the the
child had both male and female
reproductive organs and the result of
that was that the seven-year-old child
killed by the father for reasons of
pride or shame or any number of those
things I wondered
we've talked a lot about middle-class
Muslims and we've talked about wealthier
more developed countries and I wondered
to what extent is what I've heard about
or experienced representative of rural
more impoverished Muslim countries Iraq
is a is a is it's a specific case in the
in the Arab region and I focus mainly on
Egypt and other countries which I
thought offered models of how to move
forward on some of the sexual hang-ups
in Egypt because it's important to get
things to work in Egypt because if they
work in Egypt they're most like more
likely to be exported to places like
Iraq the transfer doesn't occur the
other way Iraq is a special is a special
case because of the conflict and the
poverty and all the dynamics that are
going on there that are really not are
exceptional this is not these are
exceptional times and there are unusual
behaviors I have to say in the case of
the soldiers having relations with each
other of course it happens it's
documented across the Arab region and
because of sex segregation basically
it's often easier and because of there
is a cover of homo sociality so men
you're walking in the streets of the
Arab world you'll see men holding hands
you'll see men kissing on the cheek for
example or rubbing noses but if it were
a man and a woman doing that there would
be outrage in many in in many quarters
um and it doesn't mean it doesn't signal
gayness it's something else it's just
guys being friendly absolutely and in
part because there are these barriers
are they're very formalized in some
countries like in Saudi Arabia where
it's much more institutionalized or even
their sort of self-imposed you do find
these very strong same-sex interactions
but there
necessarily sexual on the point of the
the poor child who is a essentially
hermaphrodite injustice intersex yeah um
that actually sex change operations in
Sunni Islam are permitted and in fact
there are a number of fatwas from across
the region which permit sex change
operations in those circumstances in
fact one of the world's leading centers
for sex change surgery is in fact in
Saudi Arabia and where they're doing
hundreds of surgeries on intersex the
difficulty becomes on transgendered
individuals and in Sunni Islam the
majority opinion is that no it's a bit
of fudge factor here but generally
speaking if you just have this as a
sexual identity question or gender
identity question the answer is no you
can't be changed but what's interesting
is that in Shia Islam it's very
different
she Islam when there was a fatwa from
the Ayatollah Khomeini which actually
permits sex change operations in such
circumstances but that made to be be do
morally what happened to that child
maybe do more as we say it's a rural
area it's ignorant but the principle
remains it's about the family honor
about the collective honor and that's
the single biggest in my opinion the one
of the biggest obstacles to achieving
anything close to sexual rights so that
that dead child oh sorry
in white in a Ronnie remain in Iraq in
Iraq sorry the war I don't look at Iraq
oh sorry so I can't I can't comment on
that because I did not do my research in
Iraq my research was focused on on on
Egypt do you want to just tell us
quickly which countries you visit in the
book obviously Egypt Saudi Arabia Qatar
I talk to people in Oman Lebanon talk to
people in Jordan great great story with
we're talking to Palestinians and in
Israel some really innovative work there
and talk to also talk to people with
doing work in Syria I wanted to ask
still happens we simply don't know I
mean they are by definition shadowy and
there is no reliable there's absolutely
no reliable evidence on that it's
certainly a man II the woman I mentioned
who wanted to get married and her
parents said no well she said one of the
issues is that honour killing it happens
you know and it happened in my family my
one of my relatives Nobel generations
ago she went and the story has kept
alive to keep the girls girls in line
the statistics are very poor what I can
tell you is that I have come across
academics who have told me a very
interesting phenomenon which is the
false honour crime and which men will
actually have killed a female member for
let's say money financial reasons but
will actually say it's an honour crime
because it actually gives them a reduced
sentence mm-hmm my other question was
you said that marriage is the Citadel
what is sex
typical marriage and art art I mean it's
a very good question it is hard to
answer because the problem is that we
don't have a Kinsey Report we don't have
a hype report we don't really have any
basis for answering that question and I
call for it and in my book I can only
give you anecdote and in my experience
in talking to couples women are
frustrated let me turn that around
actually I don't want to talk about in
negative terms I want to talk about it
in terms of belonging they are longing
for better communication with their
husbands they're longing for more spark
in their in their marriage they want
romance the men I met and again these
are snapshots I don't please don't
generalize from this extrapolate from
this but they were frustrated they
wanted more and yet when their wives
tried to show some spark they were
horrified I'm one of these instances I
talk about in the book a young woman who
was reading up before marriage wanted to
this was her big night and when she
initiated some activity her husband
hauled her out a bit and made her swear
on a korón that she had never had
relations before marriage bit of a
downer for the rest of the Nights
proceeding
so in my experience there is a sort of
conflict going on people want more but
they're not sure how to achieve more but
I think in the years to come because we
are heading into what I hope is a
different period in Egyptian history and
and it ferment for much of the region
you know once we get through this very
tricky transitional period and no one's
certain how long that's gonna last
I could hear heading into a better into
a better place people can now start
talking about these issues just as the
gentleman who asked about the rapes and
in Tucker virginity testing the one
positive thing that's coming out of all
this is willingness to speak openly now
about sexual violence 10 years ago when
a woman who was raped she would never
speak out and now people are coming to
the fore and the key at the end of the
day is switching this increasing
openness about sex to talking not just
about sex as a crisis or a scandal or a
tragedy but sex is something positive
and sex as a real force for empowerment
of men and women for well-being and the
reason I keep going back to the old
literature is that there was an ability
of thousand years to go to find the fun
in sex and to talk about it as a source
of power for it for for for men and
women and we have lost that and I hope
that we can recapture that in in the
decades to come - - two final questions
I'm afraid we're going to maybe if
they're going to be very very short but
you guys except this book one of the
back and then one here and that's gonna
be a mess unless unless it was going
really really quick
I just might ask actually about the
healthcare infrastructure and training
for health professionals and its really
as it pertains to hiv/aids and how open
they are have trained there not only and
testing but in treating and what that
looks like okay I'm gonna the interests
of brevity I'm just gonna speak about
Egypt I mean some of the worst stigma
and discrimination that people living
with HIV encounter is amongst healthcare
professionals
it is truly appalling I've done work
with women living with HIV and they have
for example have been unable to find
anyone who will deliver their babies
because of the fear of contracting HIV
amongst health care professionals
because the education is so poor but
also because of the stigma that these
women are seen as bad women because they
have somehow engaged the assumption is
that they've had sex outside of marriage
and yet the majority of women who
contract HIV in the Arab world got it
from their husbands but and homophobia
is horrendous truly horrendous in the
medical in the medical profession but I
can tell you a funny story the there's
so little sexuality education in in
medical schools in most of the Arab
region it's starting but it's still
rudimentary Heba OTT who's arguably the
Arab world's most famous sex therapist
she had a show on on television she's a
celebrity in Egypt and much of the Arab
world the only class in Cairo Cairo
Medical School that she had on sexuality
was cancelled due to freak rain and that
was it basically freak rain off rain
storm and that was it one class in the
course of all and as a consequence of
this you often find for example doctors
are the major major performers of FGM
and many of them will endorse it they
think circumcision is a good thing
because they themselves have very little
knowledge of sexual anatomy or the more
complex aspects of sexuality so there's
a lot to be done and also on
on on hiv/aids education amongst
healthcare professionals will hey I
don't think it is a dismal picture I
find this really interesting because a
lot of my book is talking about the
solutions that people who are trying to
achieve happiness in their sexual lives
whether it's an individual choices or
it's community projects or even trying
to change national law so my book is
actually quite it's quite hopeful and I
am quite optimistic I think the problem
is not Islam I think the problem are the
interpretations that we as Muslims have
imposed upon it and why we have
gravitated to these very restrictive
interpretations when we could have wider
interpretations but as you say it's not
unique to Islam and one of the most
interesting aspects of writing this book
was talking to some very innovative
Palestinians living in Israel and
listening to them talk about sexual
culture in Israel as well and that
seeing the parallels between some of
them worth the dogs of followers of
Judaism I mean it's not far off what we
see in Islamic conservatives as well I
think the key issue and the difference
to how change came about in the West is
that the majority of people I have met
in the Arab world do not want to put
religion to their backs they want to
whether they're Muslims or Christians
they want to live within the parameters
of their faith and so that's why I'm
arguing the book if we're going to do
that and I respect anyone who chooses to
do that and I think you should have the
choice to do that but it should not be
imposed by the state but we are very far
from that but if okay we're gonna live
within those parameters there is
flexibility there is a spectrum within
these
let us ask questions let us explore it
so one we have one more question
sit sit sit sit sit since you will be
very very patient and you're obviously
eager to carry on talking one last bit
too many questions
well maybe you could relate them my I
guess I'm wondering if you can share any
experiences in which or stories in which
you were surprised with in your research
with what you found and two if the issue
of female masturbation ever came up with
your subjects or is that so tab with
that even in demo yoga no masturbation
is let me do with the less not less
sensitive part first masturbation is a
big issue for men and and women the
standard line in Islam from conservative
commentators is that you're going to go
to hell and before you go to how you're
going to be blind deformed and demented
as well well you haven't exactly not not
not far off conservative attitudes in
most religions there are of course with
for young people the power of the
internet is you can find all this very
conservative opinion but you can also
now find alternative views in Arabic
that are discussing these issues very
very openly and frankly so it's an issue
for both for both men and men and women
and they are troubled by it for for sure
in terms of the the surprises
I think twofold I just I'm gonna talk
about general themes because they're
actually the stories are going to take
me too long to tell but one of the
disconnect between appearance and
reality the emphasis on not what you do
but what you're seen to be doing and
that really comes down very hard on on
women and I shall give you just one
anecdote about that a couple of years
ago there was a Lebanese TV show that
had an app
so it's like a talk show very
provocative had an episode on sexual
life in the Arab region and they had
people from Morocco in Egypt
talking often behind a screen they had
one episode with a man from Jeddah Saudi
Arabian who gave us a glimpse of his
sexual life and it was tame by Western
standards for sure it was almost you
know girlishly
discreet um the day after there were
thousands of complaints to the governor
of Jeddah he was sacked from his job at
Saudi and erricka Saudi Arabian Airlines
because he said that his fantasy was
having sex that was it while high club
or something
but if the fact he worked on the ground
staff is neither here nor there they
sounded uh and he was sentenced to a
young I think five years imprisonment
and a thousand lashes but what is most
interesting the sentence was commuted
but what was most interesting is that he
was not being punished for what he did
he was punished for what he said he had
done and we don't have a culture of
confession in Islam we are enjoying to
conceal our sins the problem and the
challenge we have in the years to come
is that we need to start finding a way
to speak out on these issues because
when we have this gap between appearance
and reality so many problems come in
whether it's sexual violence sexual
dissatisfaction within marriage or
hiv/aids we need to find a way to talk
about these things and my argument I
make in the book is a thousand years ago
not that we go back to that period it
was a different time there is I'm not a
sexual Salafi here okay
but what I'm saying is that our
ancestors had seemed to have an ability
to reconcile Islam with the needs of the
flesh and they were able to talk about
it and generate information and that's
what we need to recapture that spirit
you